I want to talk to you guys about the um
the negative repercussions of getting
woke and how you will then go broke by
showing you this image on the screen
this is a picture of uh just a circle I
don't think I can actually maybe I can
um just make it smaller or something
there you go it's uh it's it's a t for
timcast and it is uh it is the new logo
for Tim cast skateboard company
and uh we're gonna put on all of our
stuff and you can immediately see
everybody who doesn't understand what's
going on say independent trucks Indie
trucks people are saying Tim that's the
logo for independent trucks no it's not
no it's not you are all very wrong this
is the logo for timcast skateboard
company it's a t let me pull up this
website
independenttrucks.com do you see a logo
anywhere that looks like that here's
just the word independent written in a
very awful way that's hard to read let's
uh let's scroll down I don't see
anything anywhere with that symbol oh
what's this down here at the bottom you
can't see it but it says our logo let me
click on it about the independent truck
company logo intermitted truck company
chose the rounded cross logos at its
founding in the late 1970s from day one
the independent logo has represented the
passion for skateboarding the
independent rounded cross design is not
an iron cross which has straight sides
and is not a racist hate symbol
independent truck company does not and
has never stood for the promotion of
hate we strongly denounce all forms of
discrimination racism hate and racial
Injustice we believe in the power of
skateboarding as a positive force in the
world
well I got news for you nowhere on the
website that I've been able to find can
you see that logo they reference you see
the symbol they use now is this up here
in the top left get woke go broke I
hereby officially State wait you should
probably look for a patent lawyer to go
into trademarks and logos through the US
government before you decide because
they might still own the logo I hereby
officially State the new logo of Tim
cat's skateboard company is this rounded
cross symbol yeah looks cool and it's
not an iron cross you're right about
that that's a t or is it
the Iron Cross has flat sides we could
even bring them up side by side I don't
know maybe we shouldn't the Iron Cross
wasn't a religious hate symbol that was
the swastika the Iron Cross was the
symbol of the German uh the the
government before Hitler came to power
he basically used it I mean he did use
it but so look you have the Kaiser
independent trucks used to have that
symbol on all of their trucks in fact in
our Escape our garage right now I have a
box full of independent trucks because
those are the trucks that I skateboard
on the trucks are the metal Parts the
hangers where the wheels attached to
attach the board my favorite com my
favorite uh truck company you got it's I
don't like any of the other ones and
it's got that rounded cross symbol on it
a few years ago and I only found this
out recently they started getting
attacked by woke people because they
said that was an iron cross and it was
racist so the company dropped the logo
from all their products
all right yeah so here's what I'm
thinking okay you're right Ian maybe
they would still want to claim ownership
of the iron cross symbol that they use
for their logo all right maybe
Independent Truck Company would like to
have a public court battle about how the
Iron Cross is their company logo and
then we can argue about one why they no
longer use it and why they think it's
theirs despite the fact they don't use
it and then I'll make sure everybody
knows they really really want ownership
of that symbol that they think is racist
and got rid of hey that's a way to go
about it look man
if they don't want to use the symbol and
they've taken it off their products how
can they claim to own it they have
stated that they have they acknowledge
the backlash they acknowledge they were
accused of being racist for using that
symbol they don't want to use it and
they took it off all their products
sure they'll say yeah yeah but it is
still owned by the company I'll make the
argument that I'll call their Bluff
let's see them publicly announce the
iron cross symbol that they got rid of
is theirs because if they took it off
their products they clearly don't want
to be associated with it I accept those
terms I would love to have their 50 year
old iconic brand logo be associated with
my company instead and uh if they don't
want it sure someone in chat put iron
Crossland
they said it goes back to the Crusades
the Iron Cross yeah and just be and it
was used as a Syrian symbol back to 6000
BC I don't know exactly so I'll put it
this way there's two things to be said
they clearly uh they they took it off
their website they took it off all their
products they were saying it's not the
Iron Cross it's not the Iron Cross but
they got rid of it anyway now why would
they get rid of it because they know for
a fact it is the Iron Cross right and
they know that people were calling them
out for using it
they can't own the Iron Cross I would
actually argue one of the reasons they
may have gotten rid of it is that I'd be
willing to bet a lawyer came to them and
said look guys I know you've been using
this for 50 years but everybody is
asserting that is the iron cross a judge
will not agree with you that's an
original logo he's going to say that's a
nine across and you can argue you
rounded the edges but imagine someone
coming out and taking a swastika and
rounding the edges an arguing it's not a
swastika nice try dude not going to work
I think they may have changed it because
they realize they can't actually own
that symbol as it is and this was
like let's let's be honest the Catalyst
for this was them being called racist
and having to get rid of it but let's
play baby you want to get go broke I'm
gonna I'll I'll Tim kest skateboard
company will launch a bunch of boards
and wheels with that logo and we'll
start selling it this is what America
needs this is the way forward because if
we keep giving money to woke companies
like the skateboard company Tim's about
to take independent then those companies
turn around they Dem they donate to
Democrats they donate to rhinos like
Mitt Romney like um this this jerky this
is just the first product from Big Club
USA bigclubusa.com but we're going to be
going after things like toilet paper if
you go into a Target buy any of the
toilet papers those companies give to
Democrats give to people like Mitt
Romney Target themselves all of these
companies hate you they are donating to
people that want to destroy you and so
the only way forward you have to create
economies within ourselves you can't
keep giving your money to your oppressor
and say why aren't we winning you you
have to empower people in your own
Community to lift us up that's Tim's
skateboards that's bigclubusa.com I just
want to point out how on their website
at the bottom of the website on every
page you can see it says our logo
and then it brings you to this this
apology of like no no it's not an iron
cross we're not racist please please I
think by saying that and then later
taking the logo off all their products
they asserted it was bad and they didn't
want to use it and they didn't want to
be associated with it did they just I
don't think they have a right to claim
that that's that symbol belongs to them
and so it's
ourselves they just take it off like
within the last week or so no it's been
years when I search Independent Truck Co
it comes up on the search result on the
right the iron three years ago the
company dropped the logo from their
products but like right here on the
search it shows it that's that that's
unrelated to the company okay it used to
be their logo and they decided they
didn't want to use it anymore so I would
like to see this company argue in court
that they do want to be associated with
the Iron Cross please Independent Truck
Company stand up loud and proud and say
that the Iron Cross is your logo and
that no one else should be allowed to
use it I would love for you to publicly
announce that and and then we'll make
sure we get enough press about it so
that everybody knows that's your logo
look man this is a couple different
things I grew up skateboarding that is
the independent logo I should say it was
the independent logo and I am offended
that this company cowered in fear
because people accuse him of being
racist for using that logo whether it's
the Iron Cross or otherwise when I was
younger we had conversations is that the
Iron Cross are they Nazis and then you
know we learned exactly what Ian said
Assyrians going back thousands of years
it has nothing to do with it it is not a
swastika yeah even the swastika goes
back thousands of years to Hindu culture
it's The Wheel of Time but Hitler
co-opted that like
a rainbow yeah exactly he inverted it
and rotated it so there is some argument
my point here is
this company has bent the knee to the
woke cult and said it is no longer a
symbol used by their company so be it we
will keep the imagery and the the
iconography of skateboarding alive
and we will do it with a smile on our
faces because they don't want to I would
think but hey I'll take it I'll take the
alternative and the alternative is
independent reversing their decision
publicly declaring that is their symbol
and I'll make sure everyone hears
themselves but I think even if they do
for some reason still own like a year or
two left on the thing via trademark law
that publicly stating that it's not
their symbol it would be like legal
precedent to use exactly yeah so they
would either need to publicly state it
is their symbol and make sure everybody
knows that is their symbol they're gonna
have to say it but here's what I'm
saying I think it is honest and fair to
State based on how they've removed it
from all of their products it is no
longer their symbol yeah now if they
want to argue otherwise I'm willing to
hear them out
if they don't want to use that symbol I
have no problem using it and I think it
would be very very good for my brand to
adopt something they've abandoned
yeah why not
yeah we'll go Brooke you want to play
games we'll play games yeah you're like
forcing their hand it's the uh what do
they call it the Fafa chart
yeah
sorry that you know F around find out
yeah there's a meter of like how far you
go and then the ramifications yeah so I
was talking to some skateboarders
earlier who were explaining to me how
the industry's become ridiculously woke
in in crazy ways and they brought this
to my attention and I said wait wait
Indy dropped their logo it's like yeah
they don't use it anymore it's off all
their products they took it off the
trucks themselves and I was like so I
can use it now yeah and everybody
started laughing and I'm like you think
I'm joking bro if you told me when I was
14 that I'd have a company that had that
logo I'd have told you you were crazy
it's impossible yeah if McDonald's
stopped using the golden arches I'd snag
it up 100 what are you gonna use it for
whatever man who cares man put it on my
wall yo if you don't want to use
something because you don't want to be
called racist bro there's people who are
willing to take that opportunity to your
point though it's incredible what you
can dream and make real in this life
like don't let your memes be dreams kid
get your memes if you really want
something in this world you can make it
happen and Tim's showing you that
believe me I'm seeing that in my life
like people you have more power than you
think and most people don't realize that
did you always think that like before
you got tased I'm gonna I want to talk
about that leading up to that and then
what happened after was there a current
that went into your brain with the taser
and then changed everything like the
time stopped as you're getting tased and
like you can just see the universe and
all the secrets and you're like whoa you
know how many volts was it it's for
everybody on social media when they get
mad at me they say that like you were
tased and messed with your brain this
crazy lady on this uh social media app
called clubhouse that was calling uh
somebody a [ __ ] slave this crazy lady
she was coming at me with this stuff
like people think it's an insult other
people call me an American hero for the
don't tase me is don't tase me bro
incident so you're not like making me
feel bad the truth of the matter is
that whole thing helped Propel me
forward in life in many many ways like I
was given a at that point I would say I
was just starting to believe in God and
the night after I was arrested I was
praying very hard in jail I wanted
everybody to see that story because it
was such a crazy Injustice I'm asking
questions about whether our elections
are valid and I get thrown in jail for
it you specifically were asking John
Kerry about the secret society that he
was with his political opponent George W
bush with in the Skull and Bones secret
society that's that was the the question
that you're asking him which is a valid
important question there were also
eighth cousins they were related and
that that was a sham of an election
between the choices that we were given
uh back then sorry go ahead that was an
important question that you asked yeah
it was it's funny that I think the
reason the whole thing went so viral is
because nobody was asking politicians
real questions we didn't have Luke
radkowski that was uh really doing that
in a big Way on YouTube yet don't think
people knew of him yet Alex Jones as big
as he is now was a fraction of the size
Laura Loomer didn't exist Alex Stein
didn't exist so this is the first time
the American public at large was seeing
real questions asked that's why it went
viral on YouTube YouTube turned off the
view counter on the video that was taken
from my camera and they've they've since
Shadow banned it from search they didn't
want people to see my questions they
wanted people only to see the tasing to
see like the punishment they didn't want
people to learn what's going on and
anyway after all of that happened
yeah it was like a a great uh push
forward for me in my uh Journey as a man
absolutely absolutely I started thinking
around that time is uh the Power of
Words casting spells you know you spell
your words their spells and uh the magic
word magic and when you say double
negatives like don't be evil people are
hearing be evil evil evil evil be evil
and so you say don't tase me bro they're
like tase you bro okay I do believe that
so I try and say the the counter that is
the positive word instead of the
negative negative yes if I had known
more word magic at that time I would
have said the different phrase then
don't talk to me bro people do react to
double to negative energy as well and
it's not always a bad thing it's just
negative which it moves faster like
runaway breakdown out of clouds that's
how lightning forms it's very
lightweight negative energy
um so it there is value to negative
energy as well it's just very dangerous
because it can coagulate and get very
strong and move really fast 2023 is
going to be a really really good year
let's go I think you know there's talk
about recession and stuff maybe but
someone commented earlier today and said
no way it's actually going to be really
really good for the US dollar because
all the bad stuff is hitting foreign
countries who rely on the U.S Reserve
currency and they're gonna be forced to
buy dollars strengthening our buying
power and I'm like that sounds really
awful like an awful thing to celebrate I
guess like the suffering of others
results in us doing well but seeing the
Kevin McCarthy stuff I've had some
conversations with musicians with
creatives with pro athletes and there
seems to be we're reaching a breaking
point where people are like I'm just
sick of not being able to just talk
anymore I'm sick of the wokeness and I'm
done with it and we're seeing the
wokeness fail to actually push back in a
lot of ways I I wanna I wanna save some
of the big announcements that may be
coming out in the future but I'm hearing
a lot of really really really good stuff
about breaking the woke narrative and
breaking the mold and bringing us back
to sanity so I'm excited I was watching
I'm like I'm just just sorry I'm like
I'm going through the comments on my
post about the Indie logo and I'm seeing
the response from people and there's and
I'm getting messages from some Pro
skaters and I'm just like this is good
we're gonna win you can take over bro
the the whole Lane is available to
people with
that want to do things
history it's all woke people are sick of
it we can make things and take over and
put away let the Boomers go to sleep
it's you had your time Boomers but the
the based Millennials we're actually
going to build the new Industries I last
night I was watching a video from Dr
Robert Malone talking about the vaccines
and covid and all these things and I was
thinking like and I've been watching the
a lot of these doctors now that are
allowed to speak the the coveted
narrative has been lifted you know now
we're realizing like okay it's
transmissible you survive it usually
um and people are talking about it
they're pretty open about it I'm like
how are these people still alive I'm
thinking all these doctors and me and us
and like how are we still alive when
we've been doing this it's because we're
supposed to be because this is they're
not there to like stop us they're just
trying they're trying to do their thing
we're trying to do ours and we're better
like people speak up you can't stop
people from speaking up you never have
been able to do that
amen I could go on probably a two-hour
video monologue about that two hours
yeah I could go that is wrong I got two
hours go ahead yeah yeah let's go I was
just I'm just reading the comments and
uh I posted on Twitter and Instagram the
logo
a lot of people immediately understood
like they realized the point this
company wanted to get woke
this company was bending the need of
woke people and so they've given up what
is worth probably hundreds of millions
of dollars in brand value that you just
can't buy it's
1978 and they said you know what we're
going to disassociate ourselves from who
we are when I when I was told this
happened and I'm like I've not been
following a whole lot of skate scene
stuff company company-wise I watch a lot
of skaters and and I watch Barrack stuff
so when I looked it up and I saw what
their new logo is I was like is that
what they're doing that's terrible yeah
wow you can't read it and it still
throws back to the Cross days so maybe
they should just flatten it out and have
just the word independent because that's
illness I can't read it they've
destroyed their company yeah they've
they've decided to just throw in the
towel and it's so sad to see that
they've given me this logo but they
really don't want to use it anymore and
I'm I'm I will take it from them and you
know what all of the Heat and all of the
anti all of the all the hate and all the
woke people and antifa who are going to
be yelling at me
I'm willing to accept that negative
consequence that they're clearly not the
best marketing squad on the planet the
crazy leftists yeah you know when they
hate something our side loves it Ian
says that if McDonald's stopped using
the golden arches he'd snag it up oh
that's capitalism it'd be nuts not to
take it you know what I mean seriously
it's crazy you didn't see trucks without
the logo on in the first place like when
I grew up was to say they was everywhere
and I I looked up uh I was like I went
to the store and I looked gone it's just
straight metal and I'm like dude they
really said they don't want it anymore
I'm like I will begrudgingly take
and uh all those stickers at every skate
park and every video that has that
symbol that's Tim Cascade ports now let
me tell you something let me tell you
something if you could go to someone as
a marketing guy all the advertising
people listen
if you could go to a company and they're
like we want to hire you for an ad for a
big ad campaign and the guy said what if
I was able to get your ads back in time
they'd be like what how can you get an
ad for my company back in time watch
this and then you put on a skate video
and everyone's wearing that symbol on
their helmets on their boards yeah and
that's the symbol for Tim Cascade boards
I know thank you thank you very much
thank you thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time